hello today is the first uh
start of the the real start of uh
following my book and the films to
complement it
and it's going to take a long time and a
lot of explanation
but i'd like to first of all talk to you
as if uh
you know we're in the
2025 say
where
we've got electric cars hydrogen cars
and fuel cars
we'll call it gas
because diesel petrol
now you may be thinking electric's the
future but
who knows in
2025 they may have made some
breakthroughs there might be another
form of
fuel
coke you
and key
i've had in my body now for more than 20
years
so why am i talking about cars
it's the same as
when we train aikido
we're thinking about a martial art we
start we train and then as the years go
by we keep doing it
and we perhaps get a better car
something a little bit you know better
than the first car we ever had
but they all run on fuel
so
starting the book with tana hanker to me
the iwama
aikido that was taught to me by
cytosensei
very methodical
but very powerful
i felt his power it's
frightening even though he doesn't put
anger in his techniques
but the power that comes from him or
came from him
was
frightening because you didn't know how
to handle that as an uk
even taking gudukemi it's still a
devastating amount of power
to handle
so i want to try to get over to you
what coke you
is to me
now going back to the car
let's say i've got a gas car
and the fuel gauge isn't working
so what would common sense tell you to
do you want to go on a journey
you can't get it repaired that's the
only vehicle you've got
um
you might have a
water hose
oh i can get it down the
the fuel cap down the fuel pipe and i
can put it in pull it out
oh it's got this much in it well
i don't i know how many liters the car
holds but i don't know how many liters
this
is in measurement i'm going to guess
quarter of a tank
so my coke you to me maybe quarter full
but i'm not sure
because my gauge doesn't tell me
i don't even know how big the tank is
and that's why i'm still training today
in hopes that i can increase and
increase and get closer to oceansi
the famous film buddho
um 1950 i believe or around about then
um he shows devastating power
he was in around about his 50
in age and they say that's when he was
his uh you know most dynamic and
powerful
as he got older his coach would come out
and you would just see him moving his
hand and people would fall down
this is uh the advancement that
throwing without touching
you're actually using coke you as a mass
and you send it out your hand
if you block it by thought
or intention
then
it's you that's the problem
so let's say that you we've got to get
the cokie we've got to build the koku so
tana henka
was given to me by cytosensei in exactly
the correct way
but i had to spend the time working out
by looking at films with myself what i
was doing wrong
he would shout if you made
main points wrong but he didn't shout at
you for the small things
he thought by constant training of the
main
goal the really important things you
would work out them for yourself
he said to me in 1994 tony you will get
a red light in your head when it's wrong
and i did finally get that i didn't at
the time because i just used to follow
him believing him
so i did get this
red light eventually
so the first film i'm talking to you is
about
coke you key
how to get it
then we're going to taina inca
where we're going to start
gathering our things
first of all you're all at different
levels and you're all spread around the
world
say i'm
useless at diy
but i decided that i want to buy a house
but i can't afford a new house or i
can't afford
one in good condition
but i know that i can go to an auction
or i can buy a house
that's dilapidated
perhaps the walls need a lot of repairs
the roof might have holes in it
so
what would you do if you had no idea say
you was a computer
operator and you had no idea manual
skills
well you'd go to the diy shop wouldn't
you but um first of all if you then buy
this house
you might think wow this
what have i taken on
and the quest that you've taken on by
wanting to do aikido and continue to do
it is you've taken on this major project
you thought that it was for enjoyment
perhaps for yourself but then it becomes
quite a vast experience and you've got
to fix that and you
so you're so
what would be the first thing you'd
probably either go on youtube
or buy a book perhaps both
on diy
give you some idea
then you start buying some materials
after the diy perhaps mend the cracks do
the small jobs first
get yourself going into it and that's
what we're going to do
i like analogies
you might guess that
i need to get you in the right frame of
mind
sometimes you'll need a partner
sometimes you won't for tai no henka you
don't need a partner from what i'm going
to teach you
once you've taste and feel
key and coke you
you will never look back
you will strive
to want to
get rid of your physical
over and over because you realize it's a
burden
and you will start to refine yourself
so take this on board first before we
start talking about tanaka
you should have read the pages by now
101 to 103 including 103
and you should now be turning to page
the pictures are
scattered about
i'd like you to obviously read the words
i'm not going to
read them and repeat them because you
can read them if you haven't got the
book please obtain it through
amazon
if you want a personal signed copy with
your name that you have to um
specify it somewhere and uh like because
i send them out
okay
so
read that and i'm going to go over
the system
film-wise to complement the book so we
may not run
word-for-word picture by picture
but i'm hoping that the two are going to
give you the answers you're looking for
okay
thanks for your time in the next section
we will start
the good points and the bad points that
we can see and can't see in our own
aikido and tanhenko
thank you for your time